bonsoir monsieur le président mon temps
bernard rapp c'est à vous pour ce 40e
palmarès du festival de cannes
bonsoir claude léveillée c'est un petit
peu la folie je peux vous le dire ce
soir des des mitraillages de toutes
parts des photographes des télévisions
et j'aperçois yves montand et maurice
pialat donc yves montand le président du
jury
maurice pialat palme d'or aujourd'hui
qui me rejoignent sur ce studio
alors venez vous asseoir messieurs
marcello mastroianni également qui a sa
place sur ce plateau
prenez place voilà mettez-vous là on est
place yves mettez-vous à gauche
marcello asseyez vous vous êtes devant
la caméra voilà ça peu la folie je vous
le disais mais ça va très vite
asseyez-vous martial venu sur ma droite
un petit peu de silence si c'est
possible
voilà pendant que les invités ça ça me
rappelle rapidement quand elle les
grands moments de ce palmarès donc
maurice pialat qui a donc la palme d'or
grand prix spécial du jury l'unanimité
pour ressentir du fjord-du-saguenay tic
abou lat et il ya beaucoup de bruit mais
c'est aussi ce soir riz du 40e
anniversaire pour federico fellini pour
une telle visite a pris interprétation
masculine donc pour marcello mastroianni
et prix d'interprétation féminine pour
barbara hershey pour son rôle dans le
film de richard laube ce qui brille la
mise en scène pour rim wenders pour les
ailes du désir
et puis le prix du jury bien qui est
partagé entre souleymane cissé pour la
lumière et pouf chine yannick année le
film japonais je crois qu'on a dit
l'essentiel on aura plus dans le détail
de ce palmarès tout à l'heure mes
invités sont installés
voilà les verres d'eau circulent dans
l'espionnage moutons d'abord vers vous
parce que c'est le grand prix de la
soirée appris qu'ils étaient diversement
accueillies pour ceux qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont pas vu il ya quelques
minutes me fausse de de re découvrir
donc ce moment un peu spécial du
festival on annonçait donc que c'était
maurice pialat pour le soleil de satan
qui venait de se voir décerné par le
jury
la palme d'or c'était il ya quelques
minutes
et vous regarder un épisode lui la
nuitée à maurice pialat pour sous le
soleil de satan
et
oui c'est beau tout facile pour moi
parce que je suis un directement
concernés je voudrais je venais je
voudrais vous demander d'écouter maurice
pialat parce que moi j'ai du raid et
très frappé par là l'intelligente et là
l'amour du cinéma qui l'a même si son
film est très controversé ce soir je
vous demande de laisser parler ce lundi
je trouve qu'ils partent toujours
merveilleusement bien et ce qu'il fait
et même si on n'est pas d'accord
laissez lui une chance ce soir merci
voilà maurice pialat on va on va voir
maurice pialat et gérard maurice cas là
ce n'était pas facile il ya quelques
minutes pour vous
oh non moi je suis assez cabot alors
j'ai pas beaucoup de chez à 700 francs
sais pas je le concède comme ça parce
que ce que je tiens à dire tout de suite
je parlerai pas beaucoup plus hachée que
trop parlé par un festival c'est que
cette ça m'a beaucoup appris ce festival
alors qu'on dit toujours au ca vous avez
quoi ah ben l'accueil que le film a reçu
et surtout quand j'ai vu après j'étais
chez mon oncle à bandol et puis j'ai
regardé hier après-midi les émissions
tout plein d'autres d'ailleurs et gp je
me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait un
danger qu'il fallait pas être comme ça
qu'il fallait être plus modeste et plus
simple est que quand je vois tous les
gens qui sont venus ce soir c'est une
leçon pour moi parce que pour un petit
peu que je mette en veilleuse n'ont pas
le choix
comme ça de ce que j'ai fait mais j'ai
passé comme quelque chose qui remonte à
la surface et qui vaut mieux couper dans
l'oeuf avant que la caisse qui n'importe
quand même ce soir c'est un petit peu
d'amertume dans l'accueil
de vos collègues d'un critique dans la
salle où le la joie d'avoir cette palme
d'or c'est ni amertume ni joie jeu je me
semble pourtant je suis profondément
français mais je me sens pas français
parce que les français passent ce qui
m'entoure la fin ces phases-là justement
les français n'aiment pas gagné j'ai
gagné ici tout ça suffit et vivement
yves montand c'était donc une palme d'or
à l'unanimité vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure la maisonnée à l'unanimité
parce que nous avons considéré que le
travail qui a pu bien là c'est gênant
parce que metteur en scène qui là devant
moi le travail qu'il a ici une prairie
qu'il a réussie est un travail qui met
le cinéma sur notre niveau 1 une autre à
une autre étage et on peut forcément
bien sûr moi même je suis comme ça être
sensibles à des films que je dirais
peut-être un peu plus abordable d'être
le plus facile mais heureusement qu'il
ya des pialat qui a des codeurs qui a
dit rennais aussi pour porter le cinéma
à une autre auteur alors là je me
réjouis nouzille ont voté à l'unanimité
alors ce film a émergé naturellement il
ya un gros débat autour relativement
assez facilement fait finalement deux ou
trois devant durer on peut regretter que
parfois il y avait des mots qui leur
échappe et forcément ce du bernanos
était pas celle visible pour nous si mal
pour les étrangers mais l'unanimité
s'est faite au moment d'une façon très
spontanée et ce qui nous a vraiment
réjoui tous voilà bel arrêt mot à mot de
gérard depardieu gérard donc vous avez
le rôle principal masculin principal
dans lequel votre accès à ce qui s'est
passé dit alors ah non moi je trouve que
c'est très bien moi je ne sais pas c'est
ce qui fait que j'aime aussi énormément
maurice parce que là dessus
moi j'ai une réaction beaucoup plus put
j'allais dire mais c'est pas put en fait
c'est pas vrai c'est que dans un moment
comme celui là moi je sais pas je sais
vers midi a même j'aime tout le monde
même ceux qui me sifflent mais peut-être
que je ne suis qu'un acteur et que
maurice est surtout un auteur du cinéma
en tout cas j'étais tellement heureux
que marcello elle brille et que maurice
et la palme et que ce soit yves
président du
je vis cette année là qui ne donne pas
ce que ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs tous les gens que j'aimais
beaucoup comme monsieur cissé si c'est
que monsieur wenders parle du cinéma
commises on en parlait c'est une telle
chance d'avoir d'avoir ses envies ses
passions que ma foi je pardonne tout à
fait à maurice d'avoir levé son poing en
signe de colère
alors un mot rapide et voulait dire à
mon nom alors rapidement marche il ya
beaucoup de bruit pardonnez-nous sais
pas si vous vous entendez bien il ya
beaucoup de bruit il ya beaucoup de
monde il ya des centaines de
photographes et à une rumeur important
j'imagine chez vous c'est en tout cas à
paris marcello donc le prix
d'interprétation c'est la deuxième vague
l'obtenait la dernière fois c'était lié
à 17 dont je produis pour un drame de la
jalousie
et là vous arrivez donc la peste
explique-t-il même autrefois jallieu
avec des avions du nord de l'italie
c'est sûr mais c'est mon style s'il y
aura une autre poêle j'avais encore avec
la manière
alors déjà c'est un très beau prix pour
un rôle magnifique dans un dans un film
qui n'a pas de récompense aujourd'hui
qui est un très grand gilles qui finit
mikhalkov
oui vide match amical comme ça c'est là
la place qu'on y pullulent mais je crois
qu'au cinéma
s'il n'y a pas grand mais terrain les
attaque pas gagner des premiers c'est
pas le théâtre ou la terre il a
l'habitude c'est le héros de cinéma il
peine à celui qui conduit la bataille
n'est profitable si oui le président a
peut-être que vous pouvez venir il sait
pas pour jouer du violon metteur en
scène mais décidément fait pas du
metteur en scène où on a des instruments
très sain construite à côté fini juste
un mot pour dire que la barrière chez
nous à nous a rejoint c'est le prix
d'interprétation féminine donc pour le
film de concerts etc si c'est pour le
film s'est taillé people speak french do
you contente j'imagine qu'elle est
contente lui demande quelle est la
signification dafri à cannes pour le
comique américaine aujourd'hui mais
comme tu
bien en trois mots drame en par chez
nous explique que pour elle cette
importance est réelle et que c'est en
quelque sorte comme un rêve qui est
devenu réalité
voilà je vais vous rendre l'antenne
claude j'espère que vous avez bien
entendu suffisamment entendu on se
retrouvera à tout à l'heure
dans la deuxième partie ce journal avec
d'autres réactions et quelques extraits
des films merci d'être venu
immédiatement ou sortir donc de cette de
l'annnonce de ce palmarès merci ne
bougeait pas c'est avoue claude merci
bernard merci messieurs mesdames